Hey, there.
Welcome to Algorithms and Data
Structures for Technical Interviewing.
My name is Brin and
I'll be your guide and mentor.
My job is to teach you how to invent
efficient solutions to unsolved problems
using algorithms and data structures.
A skill you need both in a job and
to get a job.
Algorithm is a fancy word for
something straightforward,
a program that solves a problem.
At the start of this course, algorithms
might seem a bit like a magic trick.
[SOUND] You see the input to the trick,
and you see the output from the trick.
But everything that happens in
the middle seems pretty mystical.
My goal is to teach you the steps
involved with the trick and
to explain what resources you'll
need to pull off the trick.
In this analogy,
the resources are often data structures
or a common pattern in the problem.
After I've given you all the tools
you'll need, we'll do a little practice
to make sure you're ready to pull off
the tricks and technical interviews.
However it's not my intention to
discuss every little detail like
the laws of physics or what each tool
is made out of at the molecular level.
You'll be able to apply algorithms
to problems you'll face at work or
in an interview.
But not use them at the level
of a mathematician.
In a real technical interview you just
need to show that you can successfully
perform the trick and that you
understand the concepts behind it.
I'm also not trying to
explain every concept
that could potentially
show up in an interview.
I've designed this course to explain
topics that show up most often, but
you should definitely use this
course as a starting place and
continue to explore on your own.
I should also note that I'm not
expecting any prior exposure to
algorithms or data structures.
Just having the will to learn.
You should have some familiarity
with our programming language and
have written some working code
with it before if you want
to understand the practice problems
that go along with the videos, but
soon I'll make sure we're on the same
page about exactly what that means.